have your emotions been through your
emotions are better now because yeah
because you were used to be a wreck but
at times
it goes back and forth your wreck when
you first met it was a wreck when it
first met him was i
yeah well not a rat cutting my own hair
not a wreck
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
oh sorry what's up big
[Music]
[Music]
oh you are in tv are you tv guy now i
have to get a [ __ ] hair
tv guy now tv not even that oh you think
you're better than us
the reich's coming back how about this
huh
bring it back dude we need something bro
they just beat up filipino uh
jokoy's grandmother the other night in
new york yeah but you see that
because she didn't fall in line i mean
okay she fell pretty horizontal brother
what's up how you doing bob go baby she
fell near a storm drain though brother
uh oh yeah so when she got popped
what happened i didn't see it this
heartbreaking what what do you say
he doesn't know that's not real please
help demon who did this
jesus
no nonsense keith peterson this is
unbelievable we don't want keith keith
would let this go
herb dean well somebody else would have
got stopped it but even
nobody helping somebody videotaping dude
yeah how about the security guard
they didn't help that security guard's a
[ __ ] it's probably not fun doing it
though
dude yeah i know i put my comment right
there heartbreaking plm bro
this exact thing has been happening in a
lot of communities for a long time
it looks like i'm just thankful he's not
white how about theo but heartbreaking
this exact thing has been happening a
lot of communities for a long time
it needs to stop i'm glocked and getting
older
one day they gonna cross me funeral gang
daddy pineapple gang i don't think it's
a [ __ ] joke you think that's a joke
statement dog
funeral cat somebody dude i'm telling
you that's why
i would prefer to live in a state where
you could carry a weapon
because somebody that somebody a couple
of times the
the weapon thing happens that kind of
[ __ ] will stop definitely 100 percent
you don't think i'm packing heat on the
streets of l.a
you dude you don't think mike what do
you mean when you say packing heat do
you mean like uh one of
the blankets that you plug in that keeps
your arm warm no no when i say packing
heat i'm not talking about this big dick
i'm not talking about this hog in my
pants yeah i'm talking about the first
time we didn't want it
i can't believe i'm here with [ __ ]
tweedledee and tweedle [ __ ]
okay i'm [ __ ] sitting here with
before and laughter
you guys are okay no chris looks like a
[ __ ]
chew toy at one of those uh dog rescue
centers
and you look like a underwater welder in
a colonoscopy
piece of [ __ ] yeah dude theo's back baby
he goes back and he's revved up dawg
leo's ready to go dude i like to i like
to be a part of the last couple years of
your life
it's so awesome
it's so awesome it's an honor in the
last two man
you know it's just [ __ ] like this
type of footage man like a few years
from now when we do the doc about you
it's just going to be awesome that i'm
going to be in one of these yeah
patrice o'neill thing i'm like [ __ ] dude
i didn't know patrice but i know
theo i know you're great dude yeah i saw
the john blue she won
yeah dude that's true bro did i die dude
you guys will definitely be in at least
a scene
it's going to be awesome i'll be all up
in that dog hell yeah
good dude you guys are unbelievable i
watched you guys last week and you're
eating illegal seafood
a couple of [ __ ] beach homos hell
yeah get your [ __ ] together you couldn't
handle that dog that's why we had to do
it you ain't ready for that thing
i'm not in here i can eat and [ __ ]
whale abdomen dude you guys are like i
was doing that in solidarity with the
asian community bro
okay
it was tents in here last week i was in
here i came in i was eating the gooey
dick
and then i was ripping jokes where i was
like oh i'm stopping a lot
a lot of people out here with hashtags
stop the hey i'm out here giving people
happy endings and it was [ __ ] bombing
chen was looking at me
they were like it's not that's all chin
though
his starting move and his finishing move
are just looking at it
okay and that's not nothing to do with
the asian community
though it's a popular move in their
community because
nick looks like [ __ ] [ __ ] today what
is going on no nick's swagging it got
the apc shirt on though
nick is a wick and a lighter away from
being a [ __ ] unibomber
the researcher as soon as i heard about
that nashville bombing i was like
where's nick
nick's trying to take out theo oh they
call him
they call him wick davis dude that guy
nick's finally had enough man
he's finally but dynamite dude no i
watched the episode last week you guys
look like a couple of [ __ ]
homoerotic four you guys look like park
rangers in the
forest area of a home depot dude you
gotta look dude i got home i got home
after that episode came on and my girl
was like you need to cool it with the
gay [ __ ] yeah she's like it's just
enough is enough
you've done that joke now stop eating
dick stop did you slap
dicks no she's [ __ ] puerto rican girl
from brooklyn dude she'd have a fight on
youtube she slapped me with her fake
tits
yeah my mom wouldn't watch she said it
was too dirty you guys in here
she she stopped watching last week yeah
two weeks ago she stopped watching it
yeah
it was too vulgar shout out mrs vaughn
we lost the 80 year old demo
bro uh if you've seen our numbers
recently that's about our demo
did she get faxed up your mom no do mom
ain't getting
vague are you getting backs i don't
think so i mean
if they force us to i will but i'm only
doing the johnson johnson the one shot
the one
they might force you to to travel to
tour yeah yeah
oh i already got one yeah yeah you could
get that but but you but i don't know if
it's that vaccine
passport thing like in do new york where
it's digital you have like you have to
get it uh you know some type of
digital wallet thing if that's the case
and we gotta do it and i guess i'll just
get one dude
but don't do that when you got two two's
[ __ ] people up just do the one no but
i heard once
[ __ ] vaccine advice i will take it
off of estranged
youtube videos okay vaccine advice from
brendan dr brennan show up yeah dude i
know man
no offense but listen if you can fake
your high school diploma you can
fake a ever get kobe while [ __ ] are
also the same guy who texted me in the
middle of the night and told me one time
that his buddy got the secret recipe
for toaster strudels
those are secrets dog that's what kind
of friend i am
yeah that's what i'm saying let's be
realistic as to what's going on here
toaster strudel's rock yeah yeah yeah
who hates on toaster strudels dude
and this guy dude and it's my people
mate and the germans made them for you
thank you for being in here and holding
it down man when i wasn't in here thanks
for having me look at here
how was your time off dad what would you
do it was good man and i'll take more of
it
it was uh what did i do i got a home so
i've been trying to just get
the refrigerator doesn't work and so
there's no cold food so you have to keep
a thing of ice and then keep food in
there oh you go old school that's not
good it's old school dude you just moved
in the house and the fridge is broke
already fridge broke
wait dudes are you going to live full
time in in the nash in nashville
just back and forth but that gets a lot
right coming back and forth all day
every day you don't mind it not every
day that would be insane
absolutely i know i can't believe i just
said that
you so what do you come back like once a
month i'll come back probably twice a
month so what's home to you would you
say i'm home in nashville i'm home in
l.a you can't
like i came out here and went to the
beach the other day like that's all like
you know it's still great here
and shit's opening up too and she's like
the store's gonna open up in may like
the time stores are open nashville's
wide open
they will it will you guys are one
twitter article away from things being
shut down here for another
about i don't think la's the worst i
thought about this i don't think wait
until [ __ ] opens up
you mean nashville you know fomo
watching instagram
chris is going to move out here
no hayden on la i think la's a fine city
fight both of you
dude i'm happy la's in the united states
dude i'm happy like it's not
isis or anything but i'm not i i i dude
i'm oh
new york's the move east dude that's
where i'm from bro i can't you know what
i mean i can't come out
i mean dude the coveted stereo out here
i mean i can't deal with it i deal with
it i can't do it
he started nah dude for almost no reason
we're shut down he felt killed all those
old people yeah
he was fighting and then he's molesting
everybody he was molesting the old
people he killed he goes hey i'm italian
yeah first of all if you're going to be
a politician
yeah obviously you have to let like
who's not molesting
first of all everybody's molesting
somebody how do you get there why don't
we just make a chart instead of keep
accusing people yeah just be like okay
you can
get five molestations and then you're
out yeah yeah
that's what it is it's not like one it's
like everyone's got one well you know
yeah if you're a politician joe biden
they found a [ __ ] child's
side pony in his pocket the other day
like what is even going
on that's right they're going to believe
in my heart of heart that joe biden
is dead and has been dead for about four
months and he's like a weekend at bernie
sanders i think it's cgi stuff i don't
believe
you i want to see joe biden in the flesh
because i don't believe that man's alive
and i'm not even mad at it because i
mean you know kamala harris whatever but
it's just like
i don't believe that he's living i don't
believe he's living well if they if it
is cgi
they're [ __ ] up because speeches are
terrible and there's glitches
there's glitches he is right there look
at that he thought yeah he goes how old
he goes are you in what college do you
go to and the girl's like i'm 11 years
old
did he really say that there yeah he did
he's seen a video of all the things
oh you've seen it it's so creepy it's so
awesome i actually ha
i've been i've been like off the
internet i haven't really seen much dude
i feel like and i'm gonna say this out
of pure love for both you
comedians because you guys are two of
the best comedians
you and for you look like fortune
feamster
with a haircut and jacked and fitness
and fulfillment
yeah fortune yeah dude put him next to
you can we meet the fortune feedster
i look at you you look like he looks
like a crossfit fortune
feedster yeah like cross fortune yeah
cross four yeah dude i
i know man at least she's married and
i'm not she's married
she's married she got married right she
got married she has a diamond i'm pee
oh really fortunate theme should you
imagine having any work go to work every
day with tom papa how much i want and
talk about bread
top pop naked sourdough shout out tom
papa love
love tommy p i thought tom passed he
didn't no no tom papa's alive
he did right he has a cookie show and
he's got his radio show
yeah yeah is it netflix or uh serious i
gotta check him out uh
seriously radio on serious yeah yeah
yeah yeah tom pop no he's
one of his specials was done by rob
zombie dude yeah that's right
tommy papa everybody did you not have
something with
rob zombie i asked rob zombie to do my
special and he wouldn't do it and they
wouldn't
why wouldn't he do it i don't know i
think it wasn't enough money i don't i
don't think he just does them regularly
i think he does them like
it's like made to order it's like yeah
you got to get in advance it's like a
drop it's like those
uh it's like a um i could see me looking
like fourteen holy [ __ ]
no but you gotta get a zero that one
yeah look that one that went down
no one yeah there you go yeah yeah feels
back theo's bad spot on dog yeah dude
what are you doing there [ __ ] trump
rally what's going on there no
that was me i was hosting something for
yeah some [ __ ]
uh some jeans company that was outside
in the streets in manhattan and let's
just be honest in the back if you look
and the three people behind chris if you
put all them together that is
michael jackson
those people yeah but you can't you miss
one ingredient
you don't get michael jackson dude yeah
dude but you
missed all three you look at that dude
yeah that's yeah i look like fortunate
bro you look like a uh like what are you
so serious what was this for
you look like a concert you look like a
uh a hostess at [ __ ]
como's bathroom dude yeah were you even
do you see
people no dude i think i was doing so
top man top man the jeans company
i was doing outside in the streets of
manhattan you're doing stand-up
yeah yeah hosted like the opening of
this dude's flagship you look like the
lawyer for deshawn watson
and then and then and then and then it
[ __ ] fell apart and then that whole
store collapsed after that gig
oh you know everybody has a
erection problems and that could be you
if it isn't you hell it could be
you never know a strong flood comes
through town or
or damn anything severe disease
something
you could have a disease in your penis
and and you're hurting baby you hurting
what i'm here to tell you about is blue
chew bluechew.com
get lined up with people at blue chew
and they'll have doctors that will get
you
pills in the mail
that's right it's no more awkward you
got to walk into us you know
into a little shed behind a service
station and touch a man
and that's how you get a little hook up
or get you a little set up
now it's more natural than that it's
more regular than that
you they can do it over zoom they can do
it over the phone
and you get partnered up with a doctor
and they get you on them dps baby them
dick pills
uh nick news so what i'm telling you is
baby get um get them get them get them
lined up right now
visit bluechew.com
uh for more details we got the special
deal for our listeners
try bluetooth free when you use our
promo code kats at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w dot com
promo code k-a-t-s to receive your first
month
free of them nico and we thank blue chew
for sponsoring
this podcast you know i saw a video the
other day of a man getting attacked by
an
animal and i thought to myself jesus
christ
i'm glad i'm not that man
a lot of thoughts like this coming to my
head every day and their thoughts that i
don't want to be there and that's why i
need help
mental health today you can get mental
help from other people bro
think about that in the old days you
just wandered around you needed help
nobody cared you probably took your own
life or somebody killed you
but nowadays there's better help there's
a place you could call a hotline
um you could call them and they'll get
you set up with a licensed therapist man
no rigmarole this isn't your wife's
sister that you've been calling and
complaining about your wife this is a
real person who knows about help and
therapy
you know you don't have to do something
if you're in your small town there's no
therapy there's nowhere to get help the
roller rink is closed down
and used to go over there and complain
over there about a soda fountain
but that shit's all done now and you
still need help what i'm telling you
about
is none other than betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s
that's right this podcast is sponsored
by betterhelp
and king and the sting listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s
if you know anything about the rat king
you know that he's got cheese for a
brain
and uh and i got my emotions sour like
milk
and so i need help sometimes
betterhelp.com k-a-t-s
dude i want to say something i want to
say something something okay
i don't know bobby lee you doing bobby
there he is
[Laughter]
a little baby
dude i [ __ ] had three cups of coffee
already i feel like i'm legit gonna pass
out
did you after only three cubs dude don't
pass out on chin bro it'll be a [ __ ]
hate crime dog
oh we can't handle that i know we don't
let me say this you look way better than
when we used to see each other opening
anthony yeah opie and anthony dude i was
[ __ ]
going in there i just spoke to opa
yesterday he says hello i um
yeah opie and anthony well you were when
we were doing opium anthony together you
were
actively using cocaine and then you were
fingering um you were doing the
the oh orgasm meditation orgasm
meditation with the old ladies
yeah and then i was just rooting for the
new york islanders i was just going to
islanders games every night getting
tanked and then coming with a fat deer
face
theo used to sleep in the studio dude
that was good
you were dirt [ __ ] poor man you came
a long ways
oh dude and dude remember opening that
was not that long ago
like 20 years 16 gym when i got away it
started then he got an opium gym so
that's longer than five years ago no but
twenty i wasn't long in this
just five years 2016 2017 we didn't have
[ __ ] theo didn't have [ __ ]
right dysfunction let me think i had
erectile dysfunction
a cocaine problem i wouldn't say problem
i would say
you can't remember the episode you came
in it was me you sherrod car
how about that all those things we used
to do two out of the four people are
always being in studio are legit dead
carl and who carl ruiz chatta carl reese
uh who's dead
uh yeah the the cuban chef and then vic
henley
where would you guys do the show at from
siriusxm from opie
it was opening new york opinion jim
norton yeah yeah right midtown manhattan
yeah carl louise died in his sleep and
then vic henley died in the beginning of
quarantine man
well you two were carrying the torch so
let's hey both you tighten up taina
we live dude yeah i'm just saying
i don't know if you need to tell us
because you don't know apparently how
the math of we live works
we are alive right now yeah probably
we but if there but if we're taking bats
over under who's going to live longer
hold on let's go to the three of us
let's get a look at ruiz and see what is
he most
likely 900 in disguise right there
okay okay bang i almost actually am
believing that carlos isn't dead
he just came alive as brad the job yeah
dude
now he's [ __ ] learning disabled carl
the rubies
it's just [ __ ] dude car he's car or
wheeze with cauliflower
hey hey what happened to opie and
anthony they broke up right they broke
up uh
their show broke up and then opie and
jim norton were doing it and then opie
left
that show or something happened with the
contract was up and now jim norton does
the show with sam roberts
uh still on uh whatever the new series
i've been on there yeah jim and sam
jim's one of my favorite people but opie
and anthony was like opening anthony in
a way i mean howard sterling's house
but open anthony was kind of like that
original podcast thing where it was like
they were just saying doing whatever i
loved
was on the radio yeah well you would
have there would be no patrice o'neal
or you wouldn't have heard of patrice
o'neills of um the robert kelly's all
those guys blew up
i never got to go i remember going in
there dude and it was like the biggest
thing ever it was like you got to go in
it first of all you walked into the
building there's like business people
outside
there's some guy like building yeah
people major celebrities going in and
out like of series live we were we were
in the elevator once with channing tatum
like you're just like
because they're all doing other shows
but opie dude that's like and i don't
know if that'll ever come back like that
man because
siriusxm is [ __ ] close it's been
closed since no one listens you have a
show on there nobody listens and they're
not open
i don't know see it's weird it's not
though
they don't listen to the country they
listen in the middle of the country they
listen to
some of the truck drivers [ __ ] because
they they have somebody has to be
listening because they make real money
they make millions of dollars you know
who listens to them every time you get a
rental car they count those as
subscriptions
that's what nobody's really listening
but they but they pay
they pay howard stern that's a good
point then let go of my boy jason ellis
right they play howard stern
yeah they yeah they they pay he wasn't a
podcast and that's why howard stern's
uploading this [ __ ] on youtube now i
can't believe they let go to ellis man
ellis
held it down for them for so freaking
long man yeah dude that was the one
to that picture this is theo this i
remember this day was on full cocaine
because he was
trying to get some off daryl strawberry
oh wow
look at his face zoom in on his face his
nostril and hide yeah see if you zoom in
i mean his jaws like that he's got you
know
that's what it is so yeah dude strong my
mouth was closed according to me in my
head at that point
all day samurai looks sick though dude
has always looked sick bro have you ever
got a good look at samurai
every time i see him i bleed in his
presence just in case he needs something
he looks
he looks very geeked out ever you would
always know theo was on
was on coke the night before because
it'd be 8 15 in the morning he'd already
be sweating
he'd just be fully sweating just
dripping off his chin in the chair yeah
like i was at equinox
[Laughter]
because the podcast world all this stuff
is great and there's obviously way more
money here and and blows it up but i
remember
it was like fun taking the train going
in then when we do the show
hang out after yeah they had somebody in
like a closeted lesbian no offense if
anybody's lesbian but
um they had like a cl downstairs and
they would like
char like they had to like get your
identification for you you'd always be
late
like [ __ ] just figure it out yeah i'm
not gonna do anything and that's what i
think when i think about because people
at least in new york would say oh like
business why would you ever go back to
an office space when you could do
everything on zoom and
because i think like we're social
animals like people want to be around
that they want to go back to work they
don't want the coffee shop to close down
so i think it's going to come back i do
look like look at uh depression
gun violence it's gonna come back
domestic violence through the [ __ ]
roof
it's gonna come up people need each
other yeah i say do we even have a um
what do you mean here is there like a
one of those doctory looking ones
what do you want to do what do you want
yeah i'll take it let me see that [ __ ]
all right boy towards that [ __ ] right
now we hell yeah
all right give me that one yeah yeah we
want to ruin one do it dude
but don't you think like those days like
he can kind of come back when all the
all the boys get together like you being
here yeah you know and like you get
santino bobby
[ __ ] is over he's blame it dude dude i'm
in [ __ ] all different cities brothers
nobody's wearing these [ __ ] in l.a
anymore nobody dude nobody's wearing
these anywhere bro so this is the end of
this
this is the end of this dude doctor out
of your thoughts anyway yeah we are oh
yeah
yeah dude well no they are the only
place they're wearing it is la
yeah but they're not even really wearing
it even here little people are doing it
just to judge others
yeah yeah that's what it is yeah [ __ ]
that dude i'm i'm i'm kind of done with
it
i was in miami poppy open oh
whoa open there's not a mask in sight
they made fun of me
your shows were full capacity right
correct 100 like it was 2019 like there
was no pandemic
and you were performing to a full crowd
no masks no matter so you felt like you
went back in time
correct that's dope and then you walk
outside and there's a nightclub right
outside there
just every columbian with a giant ass
packed wall-to-wall
sticks to butts bro did you go in you
guys go into some bars you have some fun
huh
go out yeah dude why do colombian guys
down there
oh look i'll tell you this i met some
mexican guys the other day and they said
they don't have
the disease in mexico interesting that's
fair there's a lot of them dying in
mexico so who knows what that is could
be cartel violence but here you go
yeah spring break state of emergency
also florida just today said governor
desantis said they have the lowest rate
of cases
in the last six months they have the
lowest rate so i'm and i'm i'm sorry the
governor of texas rick abbott
said they have the texas which has had
no mass for a month has got the lowest
rate of coverage
they have a mandate where you can't what
you can't uh force people to wear masks
even in businesses anymore right
who's a mandate sounds like some girl or
one of our friends posted
yeah but you can't but yeah but if you
want to wear the man i'm all about just
giving people options dude asian's been
wearing masks forever
yeah yeah yeah about what's happening
now black people are beating them up
exactly as soon as
as soon as they show their faces where
did that get you yeah yeah
i know dude that's the best thing that
could have happened first so you do have
known each other
a black guy committed that crime if that
would have been another white it would
have been
overdue over but thank you thank god it
was a black person
yeah that did that because you have
known each other for how long theo and i
tgib dude thank god it's black thank god
it's black dude shout out black people
man
yeah love them oh yeah dude look at me
we don't you have to have uh
everybody you have to have everybody and
so theo and i have known each other i
would say
seven years look at this tj miller um
oh yeah you have seven years and look it
looks a little bit like two tickets now
here he is right here
what's up guys my name is dakota aka
goldilocks golden boy aka the fellow
with the flow
and i'm from raleigh north carolina now
i know you guys are looking for fill-ins
for the culture corner
but unfortunately i'm white as [ __ ] so
what i'm applying for
is theo vaughn's job since he abandoned
the show
and as often tennessee wrestling big
bertha i figured
you might need a stand-in things that
make me a good fill-in for theo vaughn
i got them luscious locks
and i'm very emotional
[Laughter]
rat king call up the mouse monarch and
i'll fly out to la
gang gang buzz buzz yeah nose piercing
though daddy
yeah brendan quit looking at you go
straight and look at the man's holes
he's speaking
what a freaking pervert you're looking
at oh look at his orifices and
everything
you're you're changed a lot man have
your emotions been through your emotions
are better now because yeah because you
were used to be a wreck but at times
it goes back and forth your wreck when
you first met it was a wreck when it
first met him
yeah well not a rat cutting my own hair
not a wreck
i know dude no i remember yeah you used
to wear those pants you still i remember
we called them locomotive pants you used
to wear pants like a train conductor
and and aboard yeah all aboard good
morning
yeah i remember one time my friend told
me you were in a one of the punch lines
and you forgot your pants dude you
didn't even pack pants
for a [ __ ] whole weekend and you had
to borrow the features pants i remember
that and that's the theo that that's the
theo
that i that i remember a lot man and i
um yeah dude i just know
i'm gonna give a fire speech at your
eulogy it's going to be
higher dude thanks and then i'm going to
die soon after that don't make no
mistake i'm going to draw
i'll be shortly behind shortly after
that yeah i see
my cd's flared up brandon will be the
only one that comes up
at my eulogy he'll come up to shitty
music
oh dude would be i would love to see
brendan i'm also going to sell
merchandise oh dude
no what would be [ __ ] classic dude is
that like yeah dude brendan came up with
a eulogy and just [ __ ]
bob oh i'd put it on tick-tock
immediately
go boom
okay that's my total printed
impersonation bro you got to see
like dude you're one of the only guys
who i'm almost 100 sure your funeral is
going to be outside
you're going to do it outside i know
you're going to do it outside dude
on a field bro you're
you're gonna do your whole [ __ ] outside
[ __ ] joey diaz is gonna be out
there
he'll probably jump in the hole right
after me dude he's on his way out
is this a guy or a girl take a guess huh
that's young m.a dude
that's bone thus in harmony well since
bobby schmurder's back
uh young ma had to hand her a career
back over to him
it's such a good point that's what you
get for taking somebody's [ __ ] let's go
that's what it is hey guys i got a
debate club for you
let's stop real quick and thank you for
sending this in let's be real honest
right now this guy is trying to
obviously
to go back to the asian aircraft they're
going on this guy's trying to look like
so he didn't get beat up right he's
trying to look as asian as possible
he's looking like he looks like a victim
and a perpetrator at the same time
it's very confusing he's both dude he's
both sides of the crime in one
yeah and i would look i'd throw a
straight kimono on this week dawg
to get on the right side of the coin
daddy yeah you know
this is that japanese headband yeah dude
yeah
yeah i would go full cut out
[Laughter]
i narrowed down to two home workouts
i got billy blanks ty bow
or shanti's hip hop abs
which one would you do let me know
bring that up nick yeah abe from odd
world yeah
he is odd world i don't i don't know
what audio video game yeah it was a
great video i don't know dude
it was a great video game abe from odd
world so i was my favorite game as a kid
i guess i'd go
[Laughter]
no he's cute man you could hit a button
you would fart
i read did it yeah got stuck is it a
good movie it's such a hard game
it's very good it's a video game it's
very difficult it's on playstation my
favorite game of all time
i just saw that movie with my kids on
disney plus mariah the last dragon
my son is i don't like it my kids do
but it's moana but asian here's the
thing it's moana something
my my kids you know my girl is puerto
rican so she's like she's like
i'm i'm getting sick of she said i'm
getting sick of the forced [ __ ] in
these movies
the force [ __ ] you know have to be a
woman hero have to be
you know an ethnicity hero she's like
i'm getting sick of it she's like just
make a [ __ ] real
thing just make a real that's why i like
soul so much soul wasn't about
the character being soul soul is just a
good ass [ __ ] movie with no agenda
that's how he spells it it's oh yeah
yeah it was just a good movie but right
there
my kids watched saul one two and three
look it's a youtube video of spanish
salt
saul yeah dude so ryan the last dragon i
didn't l i didn't love ryan the last
dragon i like moana the moana [ __ ]
rocks
fantastic yeah you're welcome
yeah what do you say you're welcome look
out now
i'm the king of new york
in santa fe
yeah yo you got some [ __ ] pies i do
you know the one i'm talking about
no no open the gates and seize the day
open the gates it's a season
day oh um open the gates that sees that
is that the little mermaid
no dude what's opening because i
definitely this is
trolls it's the straight men's little
mermaid newsies
he can't break us no one can make us
give our rights away
i've never seen newsies dude and i'm a
fully gay man yeah me neither bro
newsies is your national anthem i met
crutchy one night at a comedy club here
why drooled really i don't even know
i have no idea i don't know i don't i
want to know i'm i'm i wish we stuck
there he is right there look at this kid
one of the yeah handicapped who is that
is that michael rampaport
i'm sure it is oh dude rav4 got so
pissed the other night so we're doing
stand up
on the same show and um you know they
have like nine different mics there
because it
makes people do that before she comes in
just so people will love her
and uh and so anyway
what happened was uh i love that theo's
back
heroes back when theo was on cocaine
again i know it
i [ __ ] love this dude
[Applause]
dude a little vt you don't want that
coming dude
literally members of my family are going
to sue me because
that's what it is so anyway i didn't
know they didn't tell me you bring up
the next guy
right okay oh right now you did the
round stage right yes
yeah yeah supernova good show yeah good
show yeah whitley whitley boulevard yeah
over on whitley boulevard dude and it's
avenue well whatever well we don't want
to
yeah don't act like you know the streets
of our town though you know i just i i
was saying
i was saying that's at the whitley and
people like what the [ __ ] is the whitley
but it's not there's no venue called
so you forgot to bring up the comic they
didn't tell me so i thought the show was
over
[ __ ] so i'm like basically like thank
you everybody good night
and he was supposed to come out after
you and now did you rip two
bring up rav4 i did pretty well yeah
yeah yeah you know on a scale of one to
well i did
wow no because it's funny because you
like ripped and you're like [ __ ] the
show's over now
yeah i love it that's right that's all
you guys need to see yeah i love it dude
so then here's rapport with his crowd
so i get down and then rap and he was
like oh thanks for the great
introduction
i felt horrible i didn't know who it was
i thought it was just somebody up there
cleaning up he wasn't mad though
probably rapport
he probably doesn't care no he doesn't
care no no people get over that [ __ ]
it's like
whatever it happens you just make that
funny then you know what i mean oh yeah
and he did he's
i mean he did find i just felt bad about
i was like oh my god rapport's funny
yeah yeah that's i always notice now as
i've been going through the career of
the stan
and ramp parts and i wanna but the
stand-ups who always like say
no crowd worker don't do this or blame
it's like you're not
really then embracing comedy because
like comedy is like you just gotta
[ __ ] make it worse
that's my goal that's that's our job
it's like hey sometimes we may bomb but
it's really never the audience's fault
there's good crowds and bad crowds but
it's like you're tired you just have to
make that [ __ ] work
if you see the crowds a certain way and
something happened then you got to just
be able to [ __ ] improv yeah and get
in and out those are i think the the
best comedians are and i'm not there yet
i am well i think theo's there
100 percent theater deals there theo's
there dude i mean i'll be i'll see you
guys when you get here
no he's all no stop no yeah you guys
aren't there i've been [ __ ] going on
stage giving my opinions dude
and now i'm doing megyn kelly's show
next week
i'm a guest on youtube next week because
i've been out in l.a just [ __ ]
speaking the truth dude
you keep this up and candace owen's
gonna give you a call dude that's what
it is man
that's what it is i'll do a show i ran
into jocko willing the other day at a
hotel in nashville
yeah which is pretty cool he was over
there doing candace owens as a show
but it's just funny how suddenly you
like everybody if you're not
like i feel like they just like maybe
start to push everybody out into this
right it's weak but it's weird but but
it's really because i think like
right wing oh look shane gillis i think
i think that right wing stuff
like what you think is the right wing
now or what you think is right is really
just
a 1990s democrat it's just being on the
left
the extreme left has become so insane
and wow now
even if you even if you just lean if i'm
center
i'm center and i lean left but to a to a
like a hardened like socialist democrat
i might as i'm a [ __ ] i'm fully in the
proud boys yeah so you can't really have
an alternative opinion and that's what i
think
the biggest people keep talking about
freedom of speech
and that's a problem i get it but i
think the biggest issue facing us is we
don't have a right to have discourse
i can't even bring up a topic to have a
conversation about
because i will get [ __ ] crucified for
even questions
and that is the thing that i think
that's the thing if you look at
you know history when like start things
start to be problematic
that's where it starts to come is the
true censorship because the people
on the left who champion who are saying
like we just want to be inclusive
they're really silencing everybody
correct
so it's an interesting thing that
they're guysing they're guiding their
agenda in this kind of
weird kind of fascist thing and i'm like
yo dude a lot of like the fact that i
can't even bring up the fact that i
can't even
say hey i'm gonna go do candace owen
show because i'll be branded as a
terrorist
that's the issue it's like let me go on
there let me have lead with love and
have a good heart and just trying to be
funny on anybody's platform right and
let the people decide
but that's not how it works it's already
labeled yeah so it's it's that's the
thing that
and i don't know how you come back from
that i don't know how you got to keep
fighting you got
you got to keep you saying whatever the
[ __ ] you want you keep going because
when you start censoring is when you're
going to give in to the left
like i want to be able to ask questions
about any group
any group that's not me and not have
members of that group want to cancel me
for asking the wrong questions i'd
rather have them educate me on why i'm
wrong
and then we all move together as a
society but that's not what the media
wants
because the media is only going to make
money if we're divided and hating each
other
yeah megyn kelly next week type of [ __ ]
that's the type of [ __ ] i've been doing
i've been doing [ __ ] ted talks in the
round uh on the whit league
really no i've been going in there just
you know i mean i'm here so
i'm in a new city so i'm just in there
doing my a [ __ ] i'm doing my 2019 [ __ ]
you know what i mean and people like
you're ripping dude i'm like yeah man
that's my [ __ ] old [ __ ] bro i can't
take any chances yet i'm still
i'm still hoping rogan's gonna skype in
2018
and get me on the show when it's on
youtube i'm still pulling dude
that's right yeah yeah it's weird like
uh
yeah i guess it's yeah i don't know i i
don't know it's like uh yeah you can't
have a conversation
but also like they i think the thing to
do is just you almost wish they would
cancel you like cancel me just almost
free advertising these days exactly dude
it's like can't like what do you even
cancel me from
like i don't want to be on freaking
everybody loves raymond tonight or
whatever
right right you know they can count you
from hollywood but they can't count you
from this platform
no because because well youtube could
pull your
advertising which gets dicey which gets
dicey but still the power of your guy's
career
especially with this show and the other
shows you do is in the hands of your
fans it's not
okay the fans decide who's canceled the
fans that's the first thing i said to
brian and chris
right and i was like i know you guys
going through some [ __ ] and you're
getting all this
stuff from hollywood and everybody else
on the the left
but it's up to the fans and the right
people were i mean everybody
but i'm saying the fans decide if you
have a career or not yeah but that's
that's why i think a thing like a
patreon
is such an awesome thing because i saw
like even chris is doing it again and i
think like
dude chris is ripping by the way but
yeah have you seen his podcast let his
fans decide i haven't seen it yet but
he's killing it and that's beautiful
because i'm like let the okay fine there
may be people that don't like certain
people
there's fine there's nine billion people
on the planet the ones who do like him
why don't why shouldn't they have a
right to pay their hard-earned [ __ ]
stimulus money
to go pay for his patreon or his stuff
or whomever quote unquote was canceled
do it dude but because it's really
because really like the people who
the people who have had no voice and are
like very weak and like insecure
and like never really had a career are
the people who are the loudest
you would never i have nothing to do
i've been offended by things people have
said on podcasts i would never
ever try to cancel anybody because i i'm
happy doing whatever i've been offended
by somebody else not really but you know
what i mean like things like if it's
directed at you but i've never been
offended by someone
oh not really an opinion i don't mean
offended i don't give a [ __ ] all right
that's my feelings have been hurt but
that's it
my feeling that's exactly that's how i
should say yeah feeling start but it's
like who cares dude move on man
my whole thing now with that with like
with the internet is
is two things i genuinely believe one
most of the hate on the internet is not
real i genuinely believe it to be like
some type of bot russian chinese
i was just going to say american
homegrown it's either it's either it's
it's either it's either an animal i'm
from san francisco
yeah i think that it's all coming to
create division and two
now i just when i see somebody being
hateful on twitter tweeting negative
[ __ ]
at me i'm just like man i feel so
blessed and happy to not
be them because you have to understand
the amount of pain and anguish a human
being has to be
in if they are tweeting out taken to a
public platform to [ __ ] on somebody
those people are in immense pain because
i've never
felt the right even with road rage like
when i used to get road rage and now
like somebody i see somebody with row
rage i feel bad for them because i'm
like i haven't experienced that in so
long because i genuinely love my life
and love what i do
i'm not angry if somebody cuts it off
but also getting emotional but also the
hate you get on
twitter they're not hating on you
because you're doing shitty in life
right they're coming after you for a
reason of course crushing it yeah of
course dude i was just
he's that [ __ ] wigger that we all
love yeah gang gang
i was recently spending time in their
minimal sport
dive watch and that's for underwater
activity if you like being underwater if
you like holding your breath
and pretending that you're not on the
land anymore you can do it too
the minimal sport dive watch it's so
sleek and professional looking you'd
never know
it could go down a hundred meters
now if you find yourself a hundred
meters underwater you're probably in
trouble but
your watch isn't that's right mvmt
watches have the look and quality of 400
to 500
watches that you're getting at a
department store
but for a fraction of the cost because
they're built online
and they don't need the brook and mortar
store that's right
if you want to elevate your look with
style that doesn't break the bank
then join the mvmt and get 15 off today
with free shipping and free returns
by going to mvmt.com kats
again that's mvmt.com
k-a-t-s look buying or selling a car can
be really really daunting
and i say daunting and
you know i recently got a hold of a ford
ranger truck and
took me about probably six weeks to shop
around and get things right
and eventually through edmonds
which i'm not sure if you're familiar
with them but through edmonds
i was able to locate a used vehicle in
my area
that was within my price range within
the mileage range
that i was willing to buy it they have
millions of listings on edmonds.com
they offer appraisals that's right you
put in the information they'll let you
know which you should be buying or
selling at
you can even get funding you can get an
instant cash offer
for your trade-in you can use their
price checker
over 50 years of car shopping advice it
used to be a magazine if you remember it
but it's transformed now the edmonds
vehicle testing team
is one of the largest in the industry
every year
edmonds editors drive over half a
million miles
and conduct over a thousand hours of
testing on hundreds of new vehicles
whether you're just browsing or you know
exactly what vehicle you want
edmonds is the place to go get expert
reviews accurate pricing
free appraisals and millions of listings
and more
visit edmunds.com and click the car
review tab at the top of the page
to start researching vehicle reviews and
rankings at
that's edmunds.com for cars
there's edmunds if you want to get an
appraisal visit edmunds.com and click
the appraise my car
tab at the top of the page to get your
free online appraisal today
if you just want to see listings visit
edmunds.com to start browsing
local new and used listings
just enter the make and model in the
search bar or click the used car
tab and if you just want to get a price
check how much is this thing worth
yo no dinero con micaro
visit edmunds.com to make sure you're
getting a fair quote just enter your
vehicle in the search bar
click the price checker button on the
vehicle page that's edmunds.com
for cars there's edmunds praise god baby
he's got deep breaths so good man it's
because i shaved my beard dude
is it yeah dude and i'm on winstro are
you
every time every time theo does the line
i'll shoot myself up with a d-ball
you're gonna look like jay cutler by
next week now dude i want to try
steroids though i want to i've never
done it i want to try them oh i'll tell
you about that so
i'll tell you about this dude i had a
guy look this is true one night in new
york city
one of my buddy comes up to me he's like
dude it's like 2 a.m i'm going to sleep
we've been out drinking he's like dude
i'm going to get us some drugs and i was
like all right man i'm not going i'll
give you 90
right that's my spending limit right so
i'll give you 90
for some drugs get what you can you know
wake me up and i'll do some of the
drinks
dude he comes back at 4 4 am bro
with steroids
[Laughter]
no joke the vials the face
he did like three shots right in front
of me dude went to sleep
out dude yeah yeah and i don't know what
i mean he was leaving the next day until
his eye so i don't know what he did
after that but i remember him just being
like let's [ __ ] go
did you take one you didn't hit one i
didn't i didn't because that wasn't
going to be
well you've done it in the past right oh
yeah i've done it in the past we snuck
into mexico and bought a bunch of
steroids one time and
we had to get them out of there and we
didn't know how so we put them in a
shampoo bottle right
yeah classic and uh we didn't clean it
out that good so it was like
soapy steroids right and literally for
like
six months in our town guys would come
up with syringes and like basically just
dip it in there
it's still a little better react and you
smell like herbal essence
get ready to walk
yeah dude i'm sorry for getting gay for
a few minutes on the pod man no dude
look
i'm just grateful you're here man help
it man i'm grateful you're here i'm so
glad you're not yeah
yeah dude i know it's it's slowly
converting i'm trying to keep you
well not not to the city but the mindset
you know
like i was like you know how la i woke
up today i was like maybe i do have
white privilege but then i was like nah
oh my god i just [ __ ] drew people out
of the way and starbucks was like give
me the white
the white man needs his cup yeah you
know like how did you like that
triple white mocha yeah with extra white
in it
quite can i have the white smoker yeah
you know you're really white if you
pronounce the w
yeah why dude dude my dog
but listen i got i got it's interesting
because even my family dude i got a
biracial family my kid
you know half puerto rican yeah but
their mom will just you know my girl
just be like hey listen she's told them
multiple times she's like when we're
you know when you when you kids get
older like you're gonna be if somebody
asks you on
on a on a job interview what you are
you're gonna say white
on a college interview you're gonna say
puerto rican that's how we're gonna do
it and i'm just like hey man she said
that not me
yeah no but she could say a smart lady
though she's being puerto rican yes sir
so i'm like
i'm like yeah you know but what can you
[ __ ] do dude yeah i mean you have to
like
the system here the system obviously
started out as a white system
right so it's like once there's more
diversity then people are going to
people are always going to abuse the
system whatever they can to get the
system to also kind of fit them
sure i think that's some of that's just
the phase that we're going through in
time right now
in this country right it's just like a
more diversifying of
the country and so you're gonna see the
system probably has to
adjust until everybody thinks that it's
fair but that's the problem that's the
thing right there is like i understand
what people saying it's obviou it's
obvious that there have been issues in
our country of course
but compare the united states to other
countries in the world
oh dude and tell me this isn't the best
place for all diversities and cultures
to live in
it is and when people when peop that's
the problem is
a lot of times now you're not you're
you're not negotiating with someone
who's coming from a place of facts
you're negotiating with someone who's
coming from a place of emotion yeah and
emotion and fact
never match up so i can tell you the
facts
but if you're going to leave with
emotion and you want to keep telling me
how racist this country is and
and how much you're held down that's
fine i understand that
but the facts are x y and z each
individual by individual
and then so i've learned now we have fun
on podcasts we say but in real life
which by the way
most people in real life just get about
their business and [ __ ]
live life this is little little pockets
of the internet that we think is this
huge thing but it's really not
most people like i don't give a [ __ ] uh
whatever there's issues but
i got to feed my family tonight i agree
so i'm going to go ma i need to go make
it work whatever it is and that's that's
most people
but you know it's like i think like you
know man
like look dude it's like we've had
issues you look back in history
certain problems the progress america
has made insane
unmatched dude in in now europe
two years ago a black player scored a
goal they threw bananas on the field
two years ago so it's like that would
never happen we've had a president black
president for eight years
what do you want from me now you're a
full-blown proud boy or how's that work
no part-time no i i want to be i want to
be
but um i can't there's like a whole
thing you got again
i i can't i can't you know just sign up
it's tough to get in
it's tough to get i'm in queueing for
white boys i'm fully in queueing on yeah
oh and you got it i'm lowercase q yeah
my daughter's preschool teacher's name
is mrs q that's for real
as soon as soon as because i was picking
between two schools and when we had the
interview
the the preschool well the one teacher
came and said mrs q and i said to my
girl said this is the one
she was like why i was like you'll see
i'll just say
i'm on eddie bravo's email list on his
website
yeah dude so that's where i'm at you
know but even like what i just said even
talking about that like i just wish that
we could say that totally normal stuff
but
i wish that we could go on like a
mainstream show and say that but they
would never allow
megan kelly it's pretty mainstream well
here's the thing i think i mean you're
starting
more stuff is growing for everybody like
i think that the
the the holdings of like the
some of this is the last desperate
attempts by um
old guard to hold on to the uh
narrative of everything you know and
yeah i agree like
what i worry is a lot so many people
think oh this this america is so [ __ ]
up and it's like
it's only for whites and stuff like this
but really it's just a system all
america is is a system that works
it's a business dude it is and if you
want to like battle the system
so much where the system doesn't work
anymore then the system isn't going to
work like
sometimes it's like [ __ ] sometimes
life's just shitty man it sucks for
everybody you think i don't like
there's things all the time poor white
kids oh there's a ton of poor white kids
but yeah it's just like
life's just life man i don't know what
i'm saying bro dude i know when you
listen to chet
hanks he said it's a white boy summer
it's a white
he said it's not like a trump white boy
thing it's like a jack carlo
himself dude i would love to challenge
chet hanks to like a public fist fight
and lose
that would be great for my parents just
to put that should he [ __ ] you up
and get [ __ ] up yes dude you could
battle him in a battle rap he can rap
didn't chet hanks and santino go at each
other weren't there wasn't that wasn't
there beef with chad hanks and no pod
maybe it's not andrew santino
some uh is it nick a podcast chad axe
and some somebody on a pocket i'm a fan
of hanks
my dad was in philadelphia that's what
i'd lead with always dude
philadelphia's way better philadelphia
shout out aids as well that's when aids
really had a yeah
aids doesn't even aids doesn't even
count anymore dude oh some girl the
other day texted me and said she thought
like or she didn't have aids or
something and i was like all right
she does have aids she said i don't have
aids and i was like yeah dude i don't
yeah i'd rather
i'd rather [ __ ] a girl with aids than
covet you know what i mean dude
both of you guys are just realized you
look like y'all look like crossing
guards at a sex change
yeah dude we [ __ ] cross right here
yeah dude i
[Laughter]
dude when i was a little kid our
crossing guard mrs wendy got hit and
killed by a car
yeah it's just like that and uh but it
was a black car in front of chin i don't
want to say that because your
community's dealing with a lot right now
yeah dude i know i know it's about that
chin what's going on chin you guys are
getting attacked are you guys is there
like
alerts going around in your community
are you guys is there fear
is a lot of it hype and it's just been
going on for a long time i see it on the
news more now but i don't know anyone
personally who has a family member or
friend that got attacked
and that's why i told brandon before i
was kind of like you know the most
recent one the shooting is in
in atlanta yeah with the masseuses being
mostly asian
yeah i'm like can we just look into it
more before calling it straight out like
racism right yeah but people don't agree
with me especially the asian community
they're they're mad at you yeah hot take
by
dramatically they're mad at you online
and these are online nations are they
real asians in real life
asian people are the hardest working uh
community probably in our country the
hardest one or so the mexican
i would say asians are i would say out
of you know
minority communities i would say asian
is number one hardest working makes the
most money i would think that asian
people
have to be the highest they are the most
property i have to think that
so so my point is what is what chen said
is
they're probably just going to work like
a lot of the stop the asian hate stuff
is white people
it's more white people stepping in and
be like i need to support
asian people i think are putting their
heads down and just going to work and
making money and doing what they always
did and buying it
being a very successful yes no
absolutely they're hiring security
guards and you know because they are
getting the [ __ ] beat out of them out
there
but for the most part they're going out
there and just working where the white
people are at home
being like we need to come up with the
group that helps our asian friends when
the asian people are like yeah lady i'm
making twice as much money as you
just shut up and make a sauce
remember when somebody thought rick
moranis was asian like a month ago
dude i caught one to the face bro
didn't he get knocked out and so and i
heard that it was an uppercut
if you're getting right that sucks he
probably his head went back like you
know how awkward that is
probably white off his feet it was that
sequel honey i shrunk rick moran
like look at this lady dude like you
know is that him oh
yeah this is [ __ ] up oh that's the
rick miranda [ __ ] yeah that was an
uppercut he thought he was asian and
that guy loves new york though man
yeah dude that's your people crazy
people [ __ ] shredded it's your people
we
saw it nick okay jesus christ that's the
kind of guy nick is right there yeah
nick's the kind of referee which i don't
understand in your sport also brendan
you're allowed to knock the guy out okay
then when he's unconscious you're
allowed to hit him two more times on the
ref
the ref has to because you're you're
instructed don't stop till i touch you
so when herb dean's late and they're big
boys they're going to be some
repercussions do you think brendan
sorry chris but don't you notice when
you're in that mode like
i got [ __ ] when i knocked out crow cop
because he was out and then herb was
slow to get it so i finished him off
because you don't want him popping back
up no that guy killed him
he ain't popping back up i could tell
you 99 out of 100 times
from a viewer's point of view at home
that dude ain't popular but i'm saying
when you're in there it's literally
it's like it must be different yeah
you're like in this one
knock anybody think you killed him you
ever been nervous like i think i just
killed somebody he had some good details
nothing like that
uh coke i thought just crocodile
i thought you actually like i thought
there'd be some serious
damage you hit him like clean it was
just clean
isn't it crazy his fighting does not
seem like that does he brandon yeah what
do you mean i'm not seeing his
team capable of it he just doesn't seem
not like he's the type of guy like if i
gonna fight with him i'd be nervous but
i'm like oh if i could just tickle him
in the right spot he'll fall down but
it won't the truth is he'll rip my head
off and [ __ ] down my neck okay that's
the truth like i got
more jokes lined up for brendan but i'm
scared to do them most likely they'll
use the bathroom before the fight don't
you guys use the bathroom before
i pee like crazy yeah yeah you got to
pee dude bro
yeah do you ever get knocked out [ __ ]
you ever get knocked out and wake up as
a different person like do your
personalities get knocked around yeah i
don't knocked out so much i got funny
did you start did you actually get the
idea to become a comedian after a
knockout or was that something
way before he
that guy knocked brendan into a new
career he woke up he's dave attell
we're gonna stand up live next week and
i'm out that'd be [ __ ] hilarious dude
so dude when you leave here you're going
to do work today you're working on a
television show
you think you're bad on us because
you're on tv no dude i actually got two
weeks off i'm hosting a show for true tv
called backyard bar awards
and um and uh it's called
bbw i've been calling it bbw like you
can't say that i'm like dude i'm saying
hey
i have to say you can't now that you're
legalizing acronyms yeah dude
so yeah i'm doing the show and um yeah
man i mean i
took the job i thought was telling
bernie this last time i took the the gig
to do it because we were doing it out
here
you know i was like i can go and do all
the all the podcasts and [ __ ] but now i
got two weeks off so i'm just [ __ ]
chilling you're coming over to my house
for tacos coming to your house for tacos
[ __ ] with the fam man hanging with
theo i don't know when you want to do it
this weekend yeah
let's get theo's coming too then he's
gonna fly back to nashville when are you
flying back to nashville i gotta show
there tomorrow night theo's only my
friend in here
at zany's lucy shout out lucy best
comments
manager in the game lucy best best best
club manager
great job over there she's great um yeah
i got a
i got a set over there i'm going to be
over there and i think in october in
nashville are you
zany's yeah yeah i got to look at the
calendar and see who's coming up
yeah it seems like to me what i'm
looking at
is that nashville it's like it's like
the one of the hottest spots in the
country right now for stand up because
they're open they're open
zany's a great hundred percent open
right now zany's too like you can go
sell all the tickets
you can't sell all the tickets but it's
at about i think sixty percent maybe or
something
which is going up over there i mean look
at this gary owens
these people were just there yeah here
we go but it's all banging comics
arnez j we got josh wolfe he lives there
jp sears yeah wolfe is there oh crap
adam corolla he's great
crush wolf again there it goes callan's
there every other wednesday
does he also live there as well brian
callanow basically but no his
his partner um [ __ ] steve is there
okay so so they do their new podcast
from nashville yeah god
they have a nice studio too is the
property value decent in nashville
theo is going up it's like expensive to
live there so
so in other words if you were going to
buy nashville for an investment you
needed to do that two years ago
i think so i think you could still get
in and have something you know you do it
now yeah you could probably
but it was the windows now like you
can't like in five years from now it's
going to be new york
it's going to be big prices in nashville
i think so that's what everyone says
man i don't know if he'd be that much
bigger everyone getting out of new york
and la like it's going to pop back here
so you want to buy new york
la yeah right look i think they they're
going to come back
these places aren't going to disappear
or change or anything like that i think
more the bigger things are just the
long-term
like governments of the places like how
high are your taxes gonna get here like
i start thinking about that like yeah
you know i i start thinking about that
like in a state that's having a tough
time how high are the taxes gonna get
because
he's getting recalled at least is he yes
because i think it's local government
too it's like even like in texas like
the governor's like oh mass off but
it it gets down to such a microcosm
where it's like yeah but if you're
whatever neighborhood you're living in
even certain neighborhoods inside like
certain cities have different rules well
think about this the mayor of austin was
like no
mask on so the rest of texas mass off
uh austin people realize this is very
purple a lot of blue there
right so they're they're they're they're
in austin you
uh gas company in austin april 22nd 24th
yeah the kid brendan who books is a
great guy yeah i'm doing that one at the
end of the year it's great
but uh they're not full capacity but
they're similar like
i think you can go and make money out
you know like you make real money you
can make real money man but you can do
it in arizona this entire covert i've
been making real money in arizona
texas non-stop and i've been in florida
too many times it's just popping you
just keep going back to florida doing
something
really those four austin florida uh i'm
sorry texas
florida nashville like different cities
these are guessing states now i mean
yeah those are those those are the four
big states
yeah well look right now and here's some
and here's theo's side piece what's this
what's this
that's my [ __ ] mom dude why is she up
here
uh we've got to flaunt my and i gotta
get video oh yeah
boy yeah that's like yeah but this dime
in the bank who's that who is that
huh this is aunt rhonda okay sent in by
a listener i got his video
right here aunt rhonda dude this kid
wants to fight shop next
he's a cop you gotta need a face kid
looks like yeah dude he's from
kazakhstan
the morning king it's ting crew i'm josh
from south carolina i submitted my aunt
ronda from virginia
she's a caring grandmother during the
weekdays and a cougar on the prowl on
the weekends
that's my vibe daddy dude and selling
cars but now she's sling some white
squares none talking about cocaine theo
hey man talking about male her favorite
hobbies include
young men and uh
gang gang buzz
what it bunny she likes that gang she's
like young man yeah dude well that's
it thank you slang in the mail dude i
freaking respect that
yeah dude that's [ __ ] cool she's
taking a fun time visiting that box
homie
nobody ever [ __ ] the male lady or the
male guy
even the male men do you think the
mailmen get more who gets more [ __ ] the
mailman or the milkman
well look let's be honest there's no
milkman anymore but i'm saying
historically
and i'm gonna i'm gonna i mean i just
said this the other day but let's
the male basically the male these days
is just handing your
the male to a black guy and hoping he
takes it where you think he's going to
take it
yeah let's be honest for usps it's
basically just giving the mail to a
black guy
and hoping he's not racist enough that
he'll deliver it to where
you think it needs to go yeah dude they
shoot my mail at my mother's house out
of a [ __ ] t-shirt
like in this game they say [ __ ] you lady
you we hate your son
we've seen your son's haircut bang they
scared the [ __ ] out of my mom's dog
yeah dude one thing it is scary though
about the media they make it they make a
lot of more white people i think are
more scared than ever sure i feel like
there's a lot more fear than there has
been i felt like
i feel like um which has been because i
used to feel like
less scared against uh different
ethnicities and now i feel more scared
against different
ethnicities sometimes not like an
individual moment but like this is
general invisible fear you know yeah so
i think that's the kind of stuff that
the media
social media has created that yeah
because i don't feel that at all i'm
around [ __ ] minorities all the time i
don't feel that at all you're not only
looking like a mexican you look like a
big mexican dude though
yeah i get it and you're also a former
ufc fighter so people are fearful around
you yeah that's true dude you're a
physical presence
you always think you're small and feel
looks like he's transitioning
but you should be scared i'm a former
used to work at a pizza place
okay we're the first to die when it
comes to racial matters
yeah the pizza delivery guy gets killed
immediately and dude theo looks like an
old school wife like he looks like a
historic one he does not he looks like
a problem dude you look like the most
white
yeah dude but i also look nazi white and
people are still scared of the nazis
dude but you even will carry a cardboard
cut out of your puerto rican daughter to
get clowns
every time i hit the stage i think of a
different more puerto rican name for my
daughter
her name is delilah the widest name i go
julissa maria
yeah sometimes i just call her san juan
yeah yeah because yeah dude that's to
get out of jail
a diverse kid dude that's why i have a
puerto rican daughter man it's for my
career
oh yeah you're like you're just getting
hillary crazy this is my daughter daddy
yankee
yeah my daughter here
is she mexican or not oh george okay
is she i don't know oh no i'm thinking
of uh frida kahlo
oh unibrow yeah that unibrow the unibrow
girl from the museum
you gotta be out there with multiracial
damn dude eminem [ __ ] going through
another why is this kid's hat is so
[ __ ] big
he looks like yeah dude why is he that's
eminem dude no he looks like a little
kid off sandlot
the real shitty white one with the big
bill yes he's got a big ass house
wins but he looks like a good dude no
not looks like a good dude
the main white kid who stole your body
what up
this is michael from mesa arizona
the voice like yeah the reason that
the guy doesn't obviously this guy is
first team all [ __ ] okay
he doesn't need anything else that's why
he's not there's no
there's no jewelry his
anything he has probably 22s with x i
bet he has rockford fosgate 22s
in his nuts this guy
he sounds he sounds fully like satan
dude
like like if the satan could talk in
that little nasdaq
video it sounds like this guy said dude
or sting it for you and it's uh
about organ donor [ __ ]
i think the guy will reach into your
body he wants an
organ i'm gonna tell you this if this
guy is
once an organ it's going to be more [ __ ]
bro
i am 100 certain this man has throat
cancer
sure dude he's suffering
he's got a detachable voice box 100
[Laughter]
i personally considered it but i figured
i've abused most of my organs
for the last uh 10 15 years or so
i'll tell you stop real quick this guy's
tired because he has been basically
underground railroading his own penis
[Laughter]
everywhere in a haitian wet nurse
i bet he has to carry his penis right in
a wheelbarrow in front of him
this guy his first team all meeting 100
yeah his vibe is too chilled on let's go
bro kind of be a dick move to uh
try and try and act like it might help
somebody so
what hold on does he want our organs
what do you want
what is he talking about how many
[ __ ]
old black dudes is this guy eating
i feel like dude i feel like if you
[ __ ]
pat him on the back hard enough
frederick douglass will roll out of his
tongue
[Laughter]
joe oh my biden
pretty disappointing um maybe theo can
donate his uh
his sweet cheeks but uh you know feed a
family or something but
anyways organ donorship kingdom stinging
gang tyrese jerky
dude he's going to be dead any day now
man
that's what it is somebody has to water
his penis dude i bet
i think bryan is guilty you don't have
any [ __ ]
yeah you know how many hello tushies
he's broke with his dick
bro i bet every now and then hannah
baron just pulled us up
damn this one bites bro i bet they'll
make sashimi out of this guy's
crotch when he dies dude here's what i'm
saying brother oh man
i'm a organ donor my sister got a liver
when i was a kid when i was like
seven years old my sister drinking that
early uh yeah she was drinking
yeah my mom had brad brad best milk
[Laughter]
and that's our title for the episode
brad best milk
so yeah my sister got that liver early
dude i used to go give speeches about
organ donation bro
yeah you know what my cousin who was an
emt
told me that if they see if you're like
dying at like a car accident and they
see organ donor
they work a little less hard to to save
you because they're like oh your body
can go to science she said not everybody
but that's the thing in the community
they look at your license they see it
they [ __ ] see organ donor check they
may just it's all
because again america's a business so is
that they might finish their lemonade
before they get
yet yeah that's what it is if they know
that you want to give it up but yeah man
it's true that's why and the number one
donors
for oregon look man there's no there's
no group that people love better than
for organ donation than motorcyclists
bro
donate for life that's a big one you can
you if you want to get registered organ
donate you can
do it through donate for life what is it
motorcyclists because they they're going
to die and
they're always dying they're always
dying right where most organs come from
motorcycles
you know before you get a motorcycle you
when you go to take the test they tell
you
off the bat you have a 99 percent chance
of getting a wreck
99 99 chance of getting a wreck they
tell you that do you have a motorcycle
license
no yeah dude that's one of the things
that scared me that's why
is my daughter like having a daughter
unless like dude
like [ __ ] because you have two boys
right two boys two boys see having a
little girl i'm like
[ __ ] dude when i see like girl women on
the back of like motorcycles i'm like
if my daughter ever came over like her
boyfriend had a motorcycle it's like
you can't put my daughter on the back of
that no we're gonna fight like i just
wouldn't allow i don't care if like
you're
intravenously using heroin but don't put
her on a [ __ ] motorcycle agree
that's like i don't want that [ __ ] at
all dude because you know something
happened
is when i was a kid we used to drive
from new york to florida all the time
with my what it was crazy it was it
would always be me my cousin
who's the emt my grandpa and then my
grandpa would never take anybody else
but his friend lillian who was her age
and i didn't realize that he was having
a full affair
on my grandma but he just said it was my
friend lillian so we were just like oh
lillian but he was saying nobody talk
about it
she's she's a surprise you know surprise
friend and we're like oh cool we got a
surprise guest for florida
so we would go with lillian where my
grandfather was just fully cheating on
my grandmother but it's just whatever it
is did you realize [ __ ] when you get
older you're like oh wow dude
i was complicit in ruining my
grandmother's life
but i was just a little bitter that's
what my grandfather was giving me
[ __ ] high seas taking me to cracker
barrel let me whatever i want i was like
this is great
but he told we were in like wherever in
virginia or something
and a motorcycle like zoomed past us i
never get a [ __ ] fume
and he goes we'll see that guy again
trust me he goes [ __ ] idiot we'll see
that guy again and i was like what are
you talking about just
wearing a [ __ ] [ __ ] saturn that
guy's in a motorcycle going 100 miles an
hour
right forget about it 20 minutes later
or bumper-to-bumper stop
traffic like dead stop in park where my
grandpa you know
[ __ ] whatever we don't know what
we're doing then all of a sudden we're
like creeping up the accident motorcycle
in pieces sheet over the guy dude that
exact motorcycle
is bright red and i'm like that when i
saw that i was like oh man oh wow
grandpa does voodoo
it does voodoo and it's also like
[ __ ] motorcycles like i detached from
them i'm like holy [ __ ]
ghost maker that ghost maker dude
because his body must have flew out and
they brought it all the way i tell him
i tell my son stupid people drive
motorcycles when they go between he's
like
he goes he's stupid i go he's stupid you
shouldn't do it so then he goes to
school
and one of his friend's dads is on a
motorcycle and
tiger goes oh he's stupid he's stupid
which is great
kids are [ __ ] hilarious dude yeah
kids we we went over to um
whitney cummings house the other day
like went her pool to like hang out she
was so nice to like nice
i gotta go over there she was so nice to
me and my family my girl and my kids
her the one she's renting or the one no
no her like her her house that she's
i live right there remodeling that's
where you look i live literally
in that complex across the street cross
street okay so it was beautiful so we
had such a good time
so in that so we had a good time and
then you know she has such a beautiful
home
you know sick oh they're rich i know it
was beautiful but like my daughter like
just being a kid
and she was like um we're going home and
she was like dad you like when we get
back to new york daddy like you need to
get you need to get us a pool like that
i was like baby i'm trying
you know i'm like trying so hard to like
do that like daddy's
and then and then i was like you know
i'm just trying to do like step by step
you know do this and she was like yeah
she's like but you know she was like
maybe the way to get that is you need to
dye your hair blue she's like you got to
die
on the blue hair and i was like wow like
that's what she thinks like as a as a
child she's like hey maybe if you just
make yourself like look
maybe like you need to stand out a
little bit she was basically saying like
get a [ __ ] haircut change your
hairstyle you know
change up your marketing yeah she was
like she's on to something she's on to
something
yeah so but it was great it was the i
will say
for as much as in new york the the thing
that people say is
[ __ ] the people in la i gotta be honest
with you the people are so much kinder
in la than they are in new york like
nobody's inviting you their house in
in in new york it's not happening but
out here everyone's like come hang i'll
i'll show you this i'll show you that
so whatever that stigma about la people
not being nice hollywood
i've been here for a month and a half
i've seen quite the opposition i've been
invited to my house seven times
five times and i've said no seven times
yes yes coming thursday
thursday people are uh well people have
houses here so that's probably easier
right but then i think people are um
[Music]
well yeah because in new york it's like
that's the thing it's like no one's
gonna invite you over to their apartment
because it's a [ __ ] super spreader
event it's like at least you can go
outside here
and just be like chilling but everyone's
been nice the only [ __ ] is somebody
came up to
my my daughter and uh you know my girl
and everybody in the park because
nobody's wearing masks because we're
like oh we're outside
in a [ __ ] park balboa park yep and
somebody came
to yep and somebody came over because
that's a great park right there and
somebody came over
there was like hey can you please have
your kids put their mask on piss down
their throats no
i didn't say any dude when situations
like that happen i say nothing dude i
just because they don't realize they
just walked into a [ __ ]
hornet's nest i mean she's a puerto
rican pregnant woman so she was like
take one more step close
to me and your face is going to be in
the sand [ __ ]
she goes take one more step your face
will be in the sand and then they backed
up
you know what she said and you know what
she said to me she goes as a matter of
fact i need you to get the [ __ ] away
from my children i don't trust you
she's like i'm not trusting you to get
away from my children when she said my
children i was like oh she's
using the big words she said stay the
[ __ ] away from my children
get your hand out of my pocket i swear
to god i was like oh [ __ ] i was beyond
like gang gang
but that guy dude i could see he's never
seen because people you know
they feel privileged to talk it gives
people power when they see people
without masks
because they finally can take power and
go you need to put a mask on
because i'm outside [ __ ] i've noticed
most people it's passive aggressive here
correct
and jasmine my girl is aggressive
aggressive yeah she again tell her to
run for office we need her here no she
yeah she would if she didn't have a
felony conviction she would
100 bro well look man i want to say this
before we get off man we we just you
know like i know we talk about race
stuff on here bro but
i think everybody's good there's all
types of good people and i think all of
us just have to try and lean into that
the more i lean into the negative [ __ ]
the more i it's it's the more you become
dude
it really will come out dude i teach my
child
what i try to say is you lead with love
you treat everybody with kindness and
respect
no matter what they look like don't
worry about people saying you're not
doing enough all those people are people
trying to keep causing division
anybody who comes into your in into your
physical presence you keep treat them
with kindness and respect as long as
they're treating you with kindness and
respect
and if they don't then you tell mom and
dad you know preferably dad because mom
will [ __ ]
light somebody up yeah and mom's already
got one fell off yeah
dad was getting locked up yeah no no mom
has a gun in her hand back you know what
i mean
so so that's what i was trying to say
because my whole thing is like
all this stuff that happens with our
world it's like most time like
everything is fine right now i woke up
today my family's fine if i if i saw an
injustice i would act on it
sometimes i feel like man is it better
to be less informed to have a healthier
happier life if you're trying to just be
a good person
and not trying to be racist or sex or
anything because it's like i wake up
everything was fine but then i checked
my twitter feed or the news and i have
to see the problems happening in
another place that doesn't but they're
only showing you the negative and that's
what i'm saying they're only showing
that because the
overwhelming majority of people i'm
talking about 99
hundreds of millions potentially
billions of people are just doing the
right thing
but the small percentage does a bad
thing gets exploded in the media and
then galvanizes people
to say oh there's all these issues and
then you're so ready for megyn kelly
dude
dude i mean i just said [ __ ] gown
dude i'm from galvanize
a little boring but for me and kelly
you're gonna [ __ ] crash crush it dude
yeah but uh yeah it's like uh yeah
everybody's doing good stuff and we
gotta we gotta monitor our attention
like what we focus on like
but every time i go click on something
and i give my attention to it that just
doc i'm i know i know it's cliche to say
or you guys
i don't see anything dude i post
i don't see anything but no that's the
thing whatever we give our attention
dude that's why it keeps growing too
because we even if you just go watch it
even if you just go watch it and you
don't let it
but every time we give our attention to
stuff man so i uh yeah i'm just saying
i got to do a better job of keeping my
attention you have to do it you've got
to be
i don't look at the comments at all it's
a discipline thing yeah that's all it is
i don't look at instagram stories i have
no idea what's going on you just post
the story and move on i don't see you
right
now it's a lot of romanian women online
i will say
and they are not responding to that hand
i said no dude the romanian women dude
there was romanian
girl in my neighborhood we get a slave
ship of rome
jesus christ oh my god she was smoking
hot dudes
i want to say this dude i'm glad you're
back brother you are back back home
bro good to be back chrissy d thanks for
this thank you i'll be
in naples florida this month april
i forget the dates uh i think it's the
17th or some
19th and then uh austin texas vulcan gas
company with the squad april 22nd
through the 24th
15th through 17th 15th through 17th
naples florida
and then austin's 22nd 24th yeah and i'm
going to be doing one show in uh
addison i'm coming to look at a place to
maybe shoot a special so i'm gonna be
coming over there i don't know what
night it'll be yet yeah i think it's
gonna be as an improv
yeah i know i'm gonna be coming over
there and then i don't know where else
i'm gonna be doing a tour but it's gonna
be later this year
so we're putting the dates together we
were supposed to call co-headline maybe
something in tampa oh yeah but your
[ __ ] agent said no good your agent
said told my agent hey listen theo all
sell 300 times the tickets chris will
so they're not co-headlining did he
really i said [ __ ] respect
i said respect to you but i checked i
said you keep you keep that energy
when you see me player until you keep
that energy that's mike berkowitz dude
what it is
[ __ ] it listen dude he wants dude i'll
[ __ ]
here's the thing i'm gonna send my
puerto rican girlfriend ass
dude yeah dude because if i hit you
it'll be a hate crime because i look
like
i look like young though chrissy what we
should do is the three of us should do
one show somewhere
let's do it yeah phoenix i can tell by
theo's response it was immediate no
obviously he's not in you and i will get
together we'll do it i need to do it
dude i've been uh yeah i'm at my stand
up i'm gonna be out doing stand-up again
in the summer but until then because i
got to do this backyard bar war [ __ ]
christy comedy.com patreon.com christy
comedy i'm
putting out content there that i'm the
most proud of so go check that out in my
podcast chrissy chaos
and hey babe tuesdays and thursdays
comes out god you're staying busy man
i got to do it baby i mean i got [ __ ]
my kid and i got a second kid on the way
due date july 4th the only two options
for that name you know it dude
my baby's born july 4th what's the name
theodora [ __ ] donald
[ __ ] boy or girl
you get a spanish female donald trump
dog
that's elected yeah dude
yo i mean dude if i got a puerto rican
daughter named donald trump and you
still don't want to subscribe to my
patreon
we love you man love you thanks for
having me boys brendan and theo
fighter and weight i got to go in and go
hard in the paint i do not think
i am in flow black rifle coffee i'm
ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrage is thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
trapping couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]